demi lovato getting candid about her  tough transition from childhood stardom  to pop stars success  I wouldn't store it out that young if I  could do it over again  um I don't regret anything but it was  difficult to transition from being a  child star to um transforming into a  mainstream artist on Monday Demi opened  up to YouTube Susanne Daniels in can  about her rise to fame after starting  out at just 8 years old making music is  fun Barney something that it is very  challenging you have to find your  identity and you know for so long you've  been kind of molded into something and  now you're expected to figure out who  you are very fast and in front of the  entire world so it's definitely been  difficult but it's been a learning  experience and I'm still figuring out  who I am every day  the singer turns 25 on August 20th I'm  in a new chapter in my life and she  shared what the milestone means to her I  feel like I've lived a lot longer than I  actually have  you